m
enfin
feu des lieux de travail
oui l'esbva bientôt d'avoir dit
david binney c'est du rock qu'il s'agit
du rock and roll comme l'appelle encore
ceux qui ne le devance pape pour ses
fidèles le lieu de cette religion
nouvelle un nom pour vous encore barbare
johnny hallyday vous êtes très jeune je
vois j'ai 18 ans vous avez 18 ans où
vous avez vous appelé à l'idée c'est
l'autre nom les dix mots vous nourrissez
votre un objet de français on peut
retenir et c'est pas mme soleil et
validés parce que de vacances holiday à
l'idée ça me paraissait être un nom
choisi il ya une lettre oui à verre
n'est pas passé loin tout même quand il
chante les corps des spectateurs se
tordent dans la salle comme sous le feu
de mille soleils
parfois il arrive même qu'à écouter trop
l'enfance est moins étant des 100 francs
si brûle vraiment à crier et qu'il
fallait éteindre le feu à grands coups
pèlerine mais depuis ce sinistre
mémorable le pyromane à l'idée s'est
rangé non mais c'est vous assagir un peu
nouveau pote m'a changé on est de
toujours à la mode est toujours dans le
coup vous chantez en smoking mais vous
continuez néanmoins vous rouler par
terre par exemple sont parait pas
incompatible que c'était donc je chante
toujours de rock et jeunes agit toujours
comme l'europe c'est à dire que je
chauffe le public mais vous pensez que
ça me faisait du bien de pas non c'était
cependant vrai nom c'est le nom de mon
cousin qui dansaient qui s'appelait à
l'idée et moi j'ai voulu continuer avec
leurs noms comme cela avait toujours
porté chance
seulement le truc de qu'ils ont
racontées sur le mange et amériques au
sort moi je ça m'est égal